bethenny writes me on Twitter Dave do
you have any advice for motivation for
those of us in baby step 2 it's hard to
stay motivated when it feels like Murphy
keeps hitting us with a baseball bat you
know what it is hard you're exactly
right
it's been a long time ago by a number of
years but emotionally I can remember it
like it was just a moment ago you just
feel like about the time you take a step
forward some eye knocks you back to you
know I can't get ahead for getting
behind you know you finally get a little
bit of money saved up in a stupid
transmission goes out finally scratch up
a few dollars and get the nickels out of
the corner of the couch and a stupid
heating air coughs and sputters I know
it is really hard it really is and
here's the thing I've observed in
30-plus years of doing this and having
done it myself to Shannon I having
walked right where you're walking
Bethany number one you're right it's
hard number two
this is more this thing of winning with
money getting out of debt
getting your emergency fund in place
becoming wealthy increasing your
generosity changing your family tree the
whole process is hard it is legitimately
hard one of the things that we looked at
when we realized that was we said this
process is hard but so is being broke I
mean so
being mediocre I mean normal sucks
financially I mean deep in debt worried
about every little thing
normals awful I just didn't like normal
I didn't want to stay there and so even
though it's hard it's easier than normal
it's easier than mediocre live your
whole life and your best shot its
mediocre that's hard so that's what gave
me motivation is I just said I don't I
don't be 60 and working in McDonald's in
Saint Thomas you know I don't wanna be
working in McDonald's when I'm 60 I
don't be a greeter at Walmart I'm sorry
I'm not mad at you if you're a greeter
at Walmart I'm glad you're doing
something and if you want to go down
there and you're worth 10 million
dollars and that's what you want to do
that's fine but I don't I don't want to
be working in McDonald's when I'm 65
unless it's the one I own in st. Thomas
you know I mean that's the only one I
won't be in think about it I mean I and
I'm just thinking okay so what is the
way out the only way out is what you're
doing in this baby step two and fighting
your way through it and going Murphy you
know good so and so I am NOT gonna put
up with you you are gonna keep hitting
me with these negative things and you
know I the only promise I can make you
Bethany is it's worth it to fight
through it
it's hard but it's worth it because when
you get the other side of this you'll be
like a lady I met the other day I was
down in Melbourne Florida speaking in a
Calvary Chapel they're taking their
whole church through Financial Peace
University and when I finish speaking on
Saturday night a lady walked up to me
and she said you know I'm about your age
I'm in my 50s and I just want to tell
you what happened I've been working with
this company 37 years and they laid me
off last week no notice just drop me
kick me the curb like next week's trash
she said I was hurt
mad driving home with tears running down
my face I was scared were my gonna do
I've lost my job and then she said and
then I thought wait a minute I'm okay
I've got several hundred thousand
dollars in my 401k I've got six months
in my emergency fund I don't have any
payments I've been doing this Dave
Ramsey financial piece stuff I'm living
the Hammond handling money God's ways
and I'm gonna be okay
and she said all of a sudden when I just
had to look at the reality of my
situation in then I got $20,000 in the
bank for my emergency and I got a couple
hundred grand in my 401k and I got no
payments I took that reality and I
thought you know what I'm gonna be okay
and you know what will happen is she'll
find a job making more than she used to
make at the place that kicked her to the
curb that's what'll happen to her and
that's what we prayed for her that night
that that would happen
so she's the other side of where you are
Bethany she's pushed through and then
when something bad happened and Murphy
shows up when Murphy shows up and you're
out of debt and you have your emergency
fund and emergencies no longer an
emergency it's an inconvenience you know
when you get your act together it
changed Murphy head does not have the
power over you that he used to have but
when you're broke and I remember being
broke when you're broke every little
thing is a big drama it's like
everything that can go wrong will your
life looks like a country song you know
what I'm talking about
I mean it when you're broke it just
seems like there's no way and you've got
to do something to fight away from the
broke land I mean you got to get out of
the land of the broke right so that when
Murphy shows up you can hit him with a
baseball bat because he does show up he
shows up in all of our lives only
difference is whether you're ready for
him
so you coming buddy you call you shut up
at the wrong house we're ready for you
see that's a different situation isn't
it and what we've learned is over these
30 years of coaching people and walking
through this ourselves is that our
mindset the way we look at it our level
of hope causes us to sacrifice to win if
you live like no one else later you're
gonna live and give like no one else no
discipline seems Pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
the Bible says no discipline seems
Pleasant at the time but it yields
harvest of righteousness it's a pretty
simple idea and Bethany I know it's hard
all I can promise you is worth it hard
but it's worth it
whatever you do don't stop you got this
you got this never quit never quit this
is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]